FRED SAUER: All right, the
next question from you.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: Any optimization
recommendations for e-commerce
website with 2 million visits
per month running on App
Engine iPhone?
MANDY WAITE: Wow, OK.
How long have we got?
Optimization recommendations.
I guess what we want to optimize
for is probably the
important thing here, and
we want to optimize the
performance of low for
latency, for cost.
Cost is an important
consideration when it comes to
cloud applications as well,
balancing cost and performance
is massively important.
So I think what probably I'm
going to kind of step back on
this one a little bit and say
the best thing to read the
resources that are available
in the documentation.
So we have a couple of really,
really good pages on the App
Engine documentation site.
One is called Managing
Resources.
FRED SAUER: Yes.
My favorite one.
MANDY WAITE: That's Fred's
favorite one.
Whenever I ask him a question,
he says have you
read Managing Resources?
And I say uh.
So I go off and read Managing
Resources, and I say, yeah, I
found the answer.
So Managing Resources
is great.
It tells you how to manage
your instances, manage
bandwidth, manage concurrency,
those kind of things.
So that is an excellent
resource.
There's also a
performance-related resource
on the same site.
I think they're in the same
section, probably one leads
into the other.
And that will give you hints
and performance.
Often, optimization and
performance are kind of
related and very married
together in a lot ways.
So you can take those tips as
one big set of tips, and
you'll find really good
information about how to
optimize your application.
If it's about cost, again, I
think I would say Managing
Resources also talks about how
to look at your quotas and
such, and where you're
incurring your costs.
And also, coming back to App
Stats as well, App Stats is
another really good essential
tool for looking at where
you're spending your time
in your application.
So if you're concerned about
latency, taking too long to
respond to your users, then you
can do some analysis with
App Stats to find out where
you're spending your time and
maybe tune your applications
to spend less
time doing those RPCs.
FRED SAUER: OK.
MANDY WAITE: Does
that sound good?
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
Now, I love the Managing
Resources article.
If you just do a web search
for "App Engine Managing
Resources," you'll probably hit
that article in our docs.
And think of it as
a checklist.
It doesn't tell you exactly
everything to do.
But it's a checklist of think
about this, think about this.
And you can go through
each one.
And you know your application
best, how you can tune it.
If you just want the "what's
the one thing I need to do
that I may not be doing that's
going to give me the biggest
benefit," say "turn on
Memcache." And some of you can
get that for free.
If you're using, in Python, the
NDB API, or in Java, if
you're using Objectify, which
is a third-party ORM layer,
they both have Memcache
built in.
So any time you write or read
from the datastore, it's
checking Memcache.
It can save you a lot of
datastore operations, and it
won't cost you a single
line of code.
MANDY WAITE: Wow, fantastic.
So use Memcache.
FRED SAUER: Use Memcache.
If you're not using Memcache,
use Memcache.
MANDY WAITE: I probably just
should have said use Memcache.